hello everyone
uh my name is dr elena greenswitch i am
assistant professor in california state
university long beach
and today i would like to tell you about
unusual mechanism of accent regulation
specifically the title of my talk is
regulation of acts and dynamics
by michael and slimes
first
i'm giving you an overview the static
image of your chiralitic cell and this
is a beautiful image of the fibroblast
you can find in the review by tatiana
svetkina
and as you can appreciate and you can
see those yellow ears pointing to
various types of accent-based structures
those structures are very diverse
and they formed in the cell in the
precise locations with the help of
multiple acts and regulators
and what i would like to point out here
that this is a static image it's
showing you different accent base
structures
but in reality in cell
accent cytoskeleton is very dynamic
and what i mean by this is it means that
acting structures
uh assemble disassemble
entry model continues well first of all
for all of us to be on the same page
i would like to point out some key
features of actin
and
on your left you can see a structure of
actin monomer and on your right you can
see a schematic of actin polymer
and as you can see there are several
regions in actin monomer such as d-loop
dna's binding loop hydrophobic cleft and
hydrophobic plug which are involved in
self-assembly interface
what this means that those regions are
participating
in actin actin contacts as monitor is
transitioning into the polymer
and intuitively uh we
we can
think and it would be true that if there
is some dramatic changes
on those self-interaction interface it
can affect the properties of the
resulting polymer and that's what we
will see
in a few minutes as i'm talking about
microfamily enzymes
another
key features which i want to bring to
your attention
is that actin polymer
is polar
and what i mean by that that
two ends of the polymer pointed into
minus and embarked and
plus end
are functionally and structurally
different
second of all what
we need to understand very well for the
purpose of today conversation that actin
is a mixed nucleotide state polymer
what do i mean by that
every action monomer
has an atp molecule incorporated into
its structure
as this monomer transition
into a polymer ecp hydrolyzes to atp and
inorganic phosphate
what is interesting this inorganic
phosphate is not getting released from
the filamentous structure right away it
temporarily getting trapped in the
filament structure
this leads to the scenario when the
filament has stretches of
atpi rich subunits
or protoners and we have stretches of
adp
actin which already released
inorganic phosphate why this is
important it's important because
actin in different nucleotide-bound
state has different properties and
different interactions
and the last language i want to bring to
your attention since today will be
discussing acting disassembly mechanism
is what can trigger this
transition from actin monomer to axon
polymer
and you can see on this slide above this
black air which you can see in the
center that if i take action monomers
and i increase ionic strength of my
buffer when i add magnesium ions i can
transition
my monomeric acid into polymers
other way around if i take a purified
polymers and i remove magnesium ions the
lower ionic strength of the buffer
my polymers will uh
fall apart into monomers
and this is something which we can
easily manipulate in a test tube in
vitro and this is something which we're
using for actin purification from
different sources but what we need to
understand
that a cell
in the cells we don't have this dramatic
transition of conditions right so all
acting assembly of polymerization and
disassembly
takes place under the same transitions
and what's important to understand that
those transitions flavor favor acting
assembly rather than acting disassembly
therefore there is a great interest in
understanding how acts and polymers are
being disassembled under polymerization
promoting conditions
action regulation system is extremely
complex there are multiple groups of
factors which regulate acting assembly
and disassembly
in cells and of course i'm not going to
be talking about all these factors
but i just bring to your attention the
focus of my talk today
i will tell you
how acting disassembly can be
orchestrated by microfamily enzymes
and i will tell you how action of those
enzymes synergizes this one of the known
accent disassembly factor called cofilin
or adf confidence
also i will discuss with you
how this disassembly mechanism
crosstalks to the effectors of actin
assembly
formants and prophyland
what we need to know
as monomers
are depolymerized and released from the
polymer they get sequestered by small
acting sequestering proteins such as
prophyland autism metaphor
and this is very important to suppress
spontaneous random assembly of actin
polymers in random places in the cells
however binding of actin to prophyland
is very physiologically important
because
there are
multiple action regulators which are
involved to bind the complexes of actin
and profiling and utilize them to drive
acting assembly and i will discuss with
you
our most recent work
which highlights how
those mechanisms of acting assembly and
disassembly crosstalk to each other
so first of all what are michael family
enzymes and how we know that they act
and disassembly factors those are very
important molecules
which are involved as we know by now
um to repulsive axonal guidance synoptic
structuring
dendritic pruning development of heart
and muscle
cytokinesis as well as cancerogenesis
and apoptosis
what is unique about those regulators is
a positive as opposed to most of the
known acting regulators that those are
enzymes those are biological catalysts
more specifically flavin canteen in
mono-oxygenases
and what those enzymes do is very
specific and it's completely different
from the oxidative damage we sometimes
discuss
in relation to oxidation of biopolymers
what those enzymes do
they oxidized actin
on two residues
very site specific and stereospecific
actually and those two residents are two
methylamines
in dna's binding loop of actin and this
is methanol 44 and 47 and for this
reaction you need to have nadph has a
high enzyme and molecular oxygen
what we know that this oxidation
triggers actin disassembly in vivo and
in vitro and i will show you some data
which highlights this
and also what we know now that this
oxidation can be
specifically reversed
by methionine sulfaxite red reductases
so how do we know that michaels are
acting disassembly factors what are the
evidence of it
well this beautiful work here uh shown
on this slide comes from jonathan
permanent slab
and
they have this high resolution
system to monitor active modeling most
most specifically uh this is drosophila
bristles you can see this tresol fly
in this figure
and
in the blue uh rectangular uh you can
show you can see the dresser drosophila
bristles
so this system is perfect for studying
actin uh remodeling because those
bristles are very active rich
and so what we have here
that if we drive
uh
actin
michael over expression in this bristles
we're getting this characteristic
disordering of actin is exemplified
by those two panels on the top of the
slide where we can monitor
actin
assembly state using a
gfp-labeled actin
and so you can see that we can detect
dramatic remodeling
of
actin in those bristles
if we over express
microenzyme and what it leads to on the
level of the phenotype you can see that
those bristles of drosophila they start
developing those characteristic branches
and this is shown in the red
frame over here at the bottom
and you can go ahead and compare it to
the wild type bristles which normally do
not have any branches and they just long
and a little bit curved
and so this is a very um
very clear indication that this um
michael enzyme regulates actin and
disassembles actin in vivo
but what do we know about the mechanism
how exactly this happens
and the simplest explanation would be
that uh
upon action of this enzyme we have
production of some kind of
polymerization impaired a functionally
impaired actin
and it causes this kind of disorder
so what we did
we went ahead and we checked
if this oxidized accent even capable of
polymerization
and we were very surprised to find to
find that it is capable of
polymerization
what you're looking at here is bulk
actin assembly essay
which is assisted by pyrent fluorescence
and what we have here we have
a fraction of actin monomers
which
abundantly modify
this pyramid and they do fluoresce
as monomers however
as actin polymerizes and environment of
probe changes we see this increased
inflorescence multiple fault and this
gives us very sensitive essay to monitor
bulk assembly effects
and as you can see from this graph on
the right
there are striking differences in the
kinetics of assembly of unoxidized and
michael oxidized actin at the same
concentration
first of all this michael oxidized actin
is this purple curve
you can see this very long clock face
and what this luck face corresponds to
it corresponds to the nucleation stage
which has right rate limiting step
in actin polymerization and what it
corresponds to it corresponds to
three acts and monomers coming together
and forming a nuclei which would feed
polymer polymer formation
and so as you can see
this process of the of formation of
those nuclei is
severely impaired in oxidized actin
so another thing which you can see very
clearly that those polymerization curves
are plateaued at a different level
and what this means that those acts
accent preparations unoxidized and
michael oxidized we call it mox actin
have a different critical concentration
this means that under polymerizing
conditions
they will have
different
amount of polymer
at 2.2
micromolar of total actin
and
what does this mean in terms of what it
indicates in terms of um
overall properties of this actions since
critical concentration
is a ratio of the rate constants
of
actin disassembly of the polymerization
and polymerization
it means that
the dynamics of actin is changed somehow
by this oxidation
so here we wanted uh to go ahead and ask
the question what are the dynamic
properties of this microoxidized acid
and here i will show you our two movies
and those are total internal reflection
microscopy movies
and
[Music]
these smoothies
show you a real-time
disassembly of actin polymers on this
flight surface
so one will show you an oxidized actin
and another is gonna be movie
of the
oxidized axon
so let's just look at the unoxidized
actin first
time
some of those polymers are getting
shorter
which is expected however in general
acting persists on the surface because
it's the polymerization rate's not
really that high
however
if we compare this uh to um
[Music]
the polymerization of uh
of
microoxidized actin
now i want you
uh to take a look at the movie of
oxidized acts and depolymerization and i
hope you can appreciate
how fast those filaments are
disappearing from the surface
and what we see in those in those movies
is a very interesting and very unusual
because we see this catastrophic
collapse of actin filaments which was
never seen before in for any form of
accident before and only was observed
were the microtubules
so now what i can do
i actually can use this movies
to quantify how fast those filaments
depolymerize
and over here
you can see on the slide the
quantification of such data you can see
those green and red traces which should
correspond to
oxidized and unoxidized actin and
oxidized is in green oxidized is in red
and you can see that this oxidized actin
we can observe those extremely fast
disassembly events which we call
catastrophic disassembly
now i can go ahead and i can quantify
how fast
those
this processes are
and you can see
that this catastrophic disassembly
takes place with uh with the rate of
about 85 subunits per second which is
extremely fast
however what we found and what was very
interesting to us that we actually can
artificially manipulate this disassembly
rate if we mimic
a atpi rich state of the filaments
which we would call young or freshly
formed filaments
and over here if if you uh if you look
at this graph on the right
you can see that if we add inorganic
phosphate
to
this
this
microoxidized actin you can see that it
depolymerizes much much slower and those
catastrophic events disappearing
and also
on the very right of this graph you can
see that if we add beryllium fluoride
which is compound which mimics atpi
state of actin and binds very tightly to
the filament you can see that
oxidized acts and filaments depolarize
rather slow
and that's what it tells us actually
is that
under cellular transitions we might have
a situation when filaments are oxidized
but they're fairly stable because they
haven't released the phosphate yet
so now
what we know that
michael is involved in the processes
cellular processes when
acting cytoskeleton needs to be
disassembled or collapsed fairly fast
so how exactly does it work are there
any factors which assist
acting disassembly
of
a microoxidized actin
so we asked can accent regulatory
proteins other than micro
ultradynamic properties of these
filaments
and the first factor which we examined
of adf profiling
and this is ubiquitous acting binding
protein and it's essential for viability
of eukaryotic cells it induces specific
morphological mechanical changes in
actin
and it has very distinct preference to
adp
f-actin to aged older parts stretches of
actin filaments
and the reason why we were interested in
this regulator and its potential
crosstalk is michael and oxidized actin
it's because this protein is known to
affect the confirmation of the loop
dna's binding loop and that's the region
of actin where are those substrate
metallic residues locate
so it was a potential
that those regulators can crosstalk
individual and also
this is beautiful data from jonathan
thomann's lab you can see that you can
have distinct colloquialization
of michael and cofilin introsophila
bristles
so it is legitimate for us to ask the
question if there is any synergy or a
potential crosstalk between these two
regulators
and what we found was quite striking
when we formed unoxidized and oxidized
actin filaments on the microscope
surface and we added
low constant low concentration of human
caffeine one
and you can see this on the very right
panels
you can see that on the top panel it's
it's an oxidized accent shown and you
don't see much of the disassembly but
what you can see that oxidized filaments
pretty much
uh disappearing from the surfaces in the
mixing time
meaning that those
uh those two
factors
oxidation by michael enzymes
and action of caffeine cofilin are
synergistic
another thing which was very surprising
to us and very unusual in terms of the
disassembly mechanism
is that
kofilin
gained the ability to sever accent
filaments
which are enriched in inorganic
phosphate and remember i told you that
this protein has a distinct preference
to adp actin adp acts and filaments
which released inorganic phosphate and
it's normally not effective towards
disassembly of the actin which is
enriched in inorganic phosphate but as
you can see if actin filaments are
michael oxidized then it it allows
calfillin to sever those filaments very
effectively even in the presence of
inorganic phosphate as opposed to
unoxidized filaments as you can see on
the top panels which are not being
severed and disassembled
and then we
went back into the drosophila model and
jonathan turman's lab performed this
beautiful experiment
when we
down regulated an upregulated level of
cofilin on the background of michael
overexpression and bristles and so what
you
can see
on your left
that uh this characteristic phenotype
branching phenotype is disappearing if
we down regulate calcium however you can
see very severe alterations in the
bristle morphology if we upregulate
coughing and michael at the same time
which is indicative of those two
proteins
synergizing in their action not only in
vitro but also in vivo
and based on this we proposed our first
working model of this new redox
dependent mechanism of actin disassembly
we showed that uh this mechanism allow
uh kaffilin and michael to disassemble
filaments independently of their
nucleophile bond state
and the way how it works is that michael
is getting activated it's normally
auto inhibited to allow
for very localized effects and for
instance here it's shown that it's
activated downstream semaphore and plex
and pathway
it oxidizes acts and filaments and what
it leads to and i'm not showing this
data here that those oxidized filaments
have
higher affinity to cofilin so cofilin
binds better to those filaments which
leads to enhanced disassembly in a
different nucleotide bound state
and uh leads to actin disassembly and
polymer depolymerization
and so when the propose this uh this
model what was interesting to us and
what we wanted uh to determine what we
wanted to know what is the fate of this
uh
this oxidized actin monomers so we know
that oxidation can be reversed
uh enzymatically however what we wanted
to know
if actin assembly factors or assembly
assistant factors
can drive this oxidized actin
back into a polymer
polymeric structures
and uh
what are what would be those factors and
what are going to be players here
uh as we know as soon as acting that
polymerizes it will be bound to
prophyland and we showed uh in in vitro
titration essays that michael oxidized
acting monomer
can bind to prophyland and then those
prophylaxis complexes can be potentially
utilized
by acts of nucleation and elongation
factors
so we wanted to know would it be the
case for microoxide acne cancers
repolymerize michael oxidized actin
uh in the complex with prophyland and
why this is of any interest it's because
of our data showing that even
incorporation of small percentage of
this oxidized monomers into acts and
polymers
can really alter their properties and if
this oxidized action after
depolymerization can be driven back into
polymers
that can result in long cringe effects
which would affect cellular dynamic and
function
so what we did
we took uh michael oxidized axon
profiling complexes and we asked
can the trigger their polymerization
and what uh this
graph is showing you and again this is
tyran-assisted
bulk polymerization essay
you can see that we cannot really
trigger polymerization of these
complexes
even if we add into the solution
preformed
as actin which forms as seeds that's
what seeds means in the legend of this
figure
as opposed to an oxidized accent which
polymerizes very well
in the presence of seeds because
now inhibition of nucleation by
profiling is bypassed
and it polymerizes however slower
without seeds as well and this is going
to be a green tree
i said okay
maybe actin assembly factors such as
formins
can perform this function they can take
those oxidized actin complexes with
prophyland and build the polymers out of
them
so how do we check for that so this is
the schematic of this forming protein
there are 15 mammalian formants this is
just a basic schematic
of
part of the foreign structure
responsible for a regulation of acts and
dynamics
you can see that it's a donut shaped
homodymer
and
this homodyner can nucleate accent
filaments and it
stays processively bound to the part at
the barked end of the filaments
and
this structure has a capacity
to bind action profiling complexes
because those extensions which are
showing in blue contain polyproline
cracks
which interact with prophyland prophylam
actin in reaching actin concentration
near marked end
and accelerating polymerization
so what we wanted to know can such
factors reassemble
oxidized actin which was complex with
profilin
and
what
this figure indicates and this is our
most recent
data that
no we cannot really trigger
polymerization of this oxidized actin
profile complexes
even all in the presence of formants
which acts and nucleating and elongating
factors as you can see on the right
all the traces containing michael
oxidized toxin or mox axon
appear to be flat
it means there is no polymer formation
in this system
as a poster an oxidized actin which
polymerizes very rapidly in the presence
of prophyland and diagonals forming two
and diet two and
also in the presence of effects and
seeds added
and just to tell you that we also went
ahead and we checked to other
performance from different classes to
make sure that this is really
a phenomenon which uh true for different
forming family proteins and they observe
the same thing we observe the situation
when um michael oxidized actin-profiling
complexes cannot be utilized by these
formats
and just to confirm that that's indeed
the case we again uh did turf microscopy
and
we attempted to curl
actin unoxidized
but you can see the top panel and
michael oxidized bottom panel
from labeled uh unoxidized seeds
in the presence of foramen and
profilin and you can see those beautiful
long filaments formed in an oxidized
sample
and you can see that there is no
filament crawl
in the
michael oxidized
sample
since michael was a michael oxidized
accent was complexed with profile
and another very important observation
we uh we made is
that uh this binds into prophylaxis it's
not just arrests the assembly of this
michael oxidized axon but it also
destabilizes already existing filaments
and here you can see you see the essay
where we add an increase in
concentration of prophyland
to preformed polymers
of an oxidized and michael oxidized
actin and then we determine usual using
high speed
centrifugation the amount of filamentous
actin in the palate in and supernatant
and so what you can see
that
michael oxidized the moxed actin is
destabilized
uh by profilin to much uh higher degree
than unoxidized action
and so this data allowed us to go ahead
and revise our model our working model
and now
uh we can say that this
michael oxidized acts and because of its
binding two profiling
is restricted in its ability to
reassemble into the polymers and form
either michael oxidized acts and
polymers
or
mixed polymers
and it's due to its binding to
prophyland and inability of performance
and uh will also check in a wasp as a
accent elongation promotes and factors
inability of these regulators to utilize
those complexes
and
at the end i would like to acknowledge
help of from my collaborators um all the
cellular work resources work was done by
jonathan timmons group
and i also would like to acknowledge
emil reister's group and how child group
uh
and hongsku worked with us on the
structure of
microoxidized actin filaments
and i would like to acknowledge nih
funding to the to my collaborators and
thank you all for your attention